Wednesdays PFT PM continues now with a
recurring guest he was on just a few
weeks ago before the draft now here he
is after the draft brand of being the
Buffalo Bills general manager brand and
welcome back all right pal
thanks Maya hey I got a kick out of your
comments after the first night of the
draft when you explained that you had to
tell people to physically restrain you
from trading round one it did it
actually potentially possibly happen
were there any conversations with teams
in the latter half of the round about
maybe trading back in and getting one of
those picks no some people called I
think I put the word out nobody called
me but they called Dan Morgan and Joe
Shayne asking if we want to get to the
bottom of the round and the Chiefs PR
guy Ted Cruz he texted me and said hey
want you to come up and get this he know
I know him well we in turn together way
back to Dayton Carolina but I said no I
said let's beat unless peach will give
it to me for a seventh we're sitting
back and you know the problem I think
this year and it may be more from the
standpoint of the team giving up the
future pick but like if I'm taking a 20
21 pick and I'm not even sure there's
gonna be a college football season or
maybe there's gonna be a college
football season that's going on during
the draft there's been that speculation
of a possible February to May 2021
college season I would think that it
would be hard to value a trade because I
don't know what those picks that I'd be
getting from 2021 or even work yeah it's
a it's a real unknown right now that's a
spot on Mike I mean obviously if there
were to be no season then we're just
gonna have to scale it off of you know
these guys either freshman and sophomore
tape only or freshman sophomore junior
if they were gonna be a rising senior
and I think some guys that may have
remaining eligibility may not even enter
the draft you're gonna have a lesser
pull potentially and they they may give
all these guys another year guys that
otherwise would be out of eligibility
may be able to come back for one more
year you may have a much more limited
selection of players even entering the
draft than you would in other years
yeah it'll be interesting because I do
think to your point if if a lot of guys
are going back they don't like their
stock and they're going back some other
guys that are lesser players may say
whoo
I better go now that receiver that was
ready to enemy he's going back you know
he'll only be ahead of me next year so
maybe I should I should go ahead so a
lot of unknowns you know to your point
but you know it never really came up you
know for us to you know to look to add
you know a future pick for next year so
yeah where do you where to give one up I
definitely wasn't doing that um but but
you know and some thoughts may be
wondering well how big of a deal is it I
mean think about it if the 2019 college
football season hadn't happened where
would your borough have been drafted
right yeah
dramatic increase in his play from 2018
to 2019 he wouldn't have been the first
overall pick it would have been to up
without question and he would have been
injured there wouldn't been any
questions about his health and that
would have been that and everything
would have gone there's some alternate
reality out there where it happened
where there wasn't the 2018 season and
Toole was the first pick and borough was
maybe a fifth rounder yeah there's
there's always those stories of guys
that I mean even Baker you know the year
before you know if people were you know
we were taking a look at Baker and
through the draft process when I was in
Carolina and you know we didn't have if
you were to come out and you know we
didn't have the type of great of number
one overall pick or anything like that I
think he was more considered you know a
second to third rounder if he were to
come out so to your point like there's a
lot of guys that they need that next
year to to give him that Bob to the
first round and you know one of the
things that Chris Sims complains about
from time to time a guy who would have
been a very high pick if he'd come out a
year early stays a year and for whatever
reason there's a perceived reduction in
his performance in the example that
Chris used today was Drew locked the
Broncos quarterback he stayed that extra
year things changed around him he got
blamed for the fact that team wasn't as
good and it's you know already pretty
clear that he's a good - very good
quarterback in the NFL how hard is it to
ignore what that
three year does to a guy when if he had
been out a year earlier he would have
been regarded much more highly from your
perspective how do you parse all that
out no it's real I mean look at to a
situation I mean everybody was saying
this year me a year ago that teams were
tanking for to us or he was the you know
the number one pick look at nearly young
man at Clemson right now I mean if we
had a draft tomorrow everybody and their
mothers gonna tell you he's the number
one pick and but what happens this
season does he does he regress or you
know you know does he have something
like what to where he has a setback and
doesn't play the whole year there's all
sorts of scenarios and unknown so that's
a fair point because you know if if the
kid from Clemson would have come out
this year you know would he have been
the number one pick this year even
though people already slaton him as
number one you know in 2021 so that's
very real I don't know the right answer
to it you know you have to when you try
and evaluate you try to do it in
totality the best you can and take all
the facts that you know and you know in
to his point obviously durability you
know he's a very good player I think
durability was the question which is why
Miami you know was able to select him at
five versus having to trade up to one
which a year ago they probably would had
to do you had a quarterback slide down
to round five Georgia's Jake from what
was your analysis were you watching him
as you fell and did you know there's a
certain point where you just can't say
no even though you've got Josh Allen
you've got to go ahead and grab this guy
it's too much of a value in round five
yeah you know he was not in our plans
Mike he really wasn't but you set your
board and if a player is sticking out
especially you know at the quarterback
that that's the premium position of all
sports and definitely in a you know in
our game and so you know we had a pretty
good grade on Jake and he was clearly
sticking out on our board the highest
player and you know unless you've got
three guys that you're going man we were
set for years to come why would you
ignore the premium position and that's
why we selected Jake and you know what a
community he's a winner and if you look
at what he did you know he held off
Eason who ended up transferring
and then you know we held off Justin
fields you know who's who's at Ohio
State so he's got to have something to
him it was very smart ease before very
high on the Wonderlic if he had all the
measurables he's six five with a canon
arm this would have been a god that
would have been talked about a lot
higher obviously he's got a lot to prove
and and and listen this is nothing at
Josh Allen or even Matt Barkley this was
just a player on our board like we do it
any other position that had a you know
we had a high value on him and we we
decided to choose him
I spent a lot of time yesterday talking
to Harry Rosen to the Eagles GM about
the mindset behind their decision to use
a second-round pick on a quarterback
Jalen Hertz and I think he was a bit
flabbergasted by the local reaction
because from his perspective it's simple
you've got a quarterback your
quarterback can get injured you've got
to have somebody that you trust to come
in and get it done because look at what
happened to the Chiefs they win a couple
of games without Patrick Mahone as they
lose one of those games they don't have
the number one seed in the postseason
they're not winning the Super Bowl from
your perspective how much of a factor is
it the Josh Allen I hasn't missed a lot
of time but he has been banged up a
little bit he's got that physical style
do you feel more compelled to have a
quality option behind him because
there's a greater risk maybe that he's
gonna get injured then a more
traditional pocket guy that isn't gonna
be moving around as much yeah that's
real and you know we do have more design
runs with him then you know the Patriots
head with Tom Brady or tax rates have
with Aaron Rodgers and some of these
guys so that is part of Josh's game
right now as he continues to develop
you know his skill set as a pocket
passer so it is important and again I
think Matt Barkley has done a really
solid job he is going into his last year
and and you know we'll see after the
season whether we would extend them or
not but you know from just gives us a
young player you know had a very good
value for four years and again it was
just it was too easy to Pat to too hard
to pass up you know with where we had
him with him fall into the fifth round
yeah AJ at Vanessa fall to in round two
he's a guy some thought was gonna be a
first rounder I'm trying to envision how
your thought process is going as he's
going farther and farther mean was it
screaming out to you that
was a chance this guy was going to be
gone give me an idea of just your
mindset as it's getting closer and
closer and and he's the guy you're gonna
take if he's there how nervous are you
that he's not gonna be there when it's
time for you to put his name on the card
yeah you know if you've got a guy you
know on your board sticking out or
anything like that until your until you
see the pic is in from you know the team
in front of you you you are sweating it
and in that round you know we had some
it seemed like a lot of offense when you
know starting the day you know we had
some options on defense and some options
on offense and it seemed like out of the
gate these guys went pretty quick some
of the offensive guys and it seemed like
as we were getting you know four or five
six picks away it was looking more and
more like it was gonna be a defensive
option you know with AJ you know is one
of those and by the time we were on the
clock he was definitely the easy in the
right selection for us you've got a
great defense as it is what do you see
him bringing to it yeah you know I think
you know you look and he's a sack
producer that's what he's done the last
two years you know he's long he this
guy's six five
he's got thirty four and a half inch
arms you know used to you know too high
to 60s to 70 I think he can fluctuate
his weight however we want him
I love his hand gain his hand use and
the thing is he's versatile that's
probably the best we love to have
versatility you know down the line with
guys that can play on you know for us
will be a left defensive end but on sub
downs we do see the possibility for him
to come inside and be a nickel rusher
and he had you sometimes you're
projecting Mike that these guys can do
it if you watch him just as much of his
production was inside as it was on the
outside so it's it's not something that
we have to see we'll take a C and look
at it when we get here we've had guys
before that you try that and to get
inside it's a different game feel so
looking forward to his versatility and
his production when we talked before the
draft we had a conversation about Devin
Singletary who was a rookie running back
last year what you envisioned his role
to be now you add another running back
in Zach Moss give us an understanding of
how you think the work will be
divided between those two gods yeah I
mean Devon is our starter and that's
what I think we talked about a few weeks
ago he's our guy and if we got a back to
complement him great we felt very good
with with Devon and TJ Yeldon as our
back but again our board stood out and
said take Zack Moss and so I do think
Zack brings a complementary skill set to
Devon Devon is more of a you know space
player he's gonna cut and make you miss
Zack is he's a hammer he's looking to be
physical he may make the first guy miss
but after that he's looking to you know
lower shoulder he's a five nine compact
frame guy solid and you know he's he has
what I would call my competitive speed
you know he's not a homerun vertical
four four guy but he did have some long
runs at Utah you see him once he gets up
rolling you know he can hold his own so
looking forward to that in the past game
Devon's probably a little bit better
right now but this guy didn't drop a lot
he just wasn't used he was used more in
the screen and the little flares out
there let's move on to the receiver
position and correct me if I'm wrong
here the digs trade was a first-round
pick this year a five and a six this
year and a for next year is that right
yeah we got a seven back so we swap
sixes and seven so it was it was a net
three picks so you you put that net
three picks in to Stefon Diggs and then
you drafted two more receivers and I
guess if I'm a Bills fan and I'm looking
at this I'm saying wait what's going on
here what's with this rush of receivers
we got John Brown
we got cold Beasley why so much draft
capital being devoted to that position
how would you address those concerns if
you have fans out there wondering what's
going on yeah I mean this was a receiver
heavy draft and I think that's part of
it you know we were hoping that it fell
it's something for us to decide yeah you
know I think Shawn McDermott he referred
to our guys as Smurfs at one point
during the season so you know and then
we had Diggs Diggs is our tallest guy of
those starting three right at six foot
so the first guy we added was Gabe Davis
who's a six to play around
and then Hodgins was a guy that was both
these guys were hired on boards but
Hodgins was sticking out in the
six-round and once we took gabe we
really weren't planning to take another
receiver but again you follow your board
and this guy will come in i think he'll
compete with dave you'll compete with
other you know with other guys but just
adding some size guys to the mix i think
it was important for us and then you
know it stands out like a sore thumb
whenever a team does it because it
doesn't happen very often you drafted a
kicker and there are say you never draft
a kicker what are you thinking drafting
a kicker what do you say to the people
who would say you're nuts to draft a
kicker well I'm not gonna argue with
them until we to the proofs in the
pudding so we'll see how it goes but we
just looked on the board and you know
when you get in the sixth seventh round
you start talking about which player has
the best chance to make your roster make
an impact and and there were some other
guys that we said okay maybe this
linebacker
maybe this safety whatever but we
thought this guy would come in and
compete with Steve and Aska and I saw
him up you know up close he was their
senior bowling and I thought he had a
very good week they gave him some
opportunities in practice and in the
game to hit some pressure kicks with the
whole team around and you just saw his
leg strength and in Buffalo we get a lot
of windy days Mike and having a guy not
only as a he'll go guy but being able to
kick that ball into the end zone and
keep the other team from returning it is
also a viable asset so again he'll have
to you know get go against Stephen
Hauschka and Steve had a little spell in
the middle of season where he struggled
a little bit but he finished 11 for 11
so I told Tyler when we draft him listen
you're going against the you know an
established veteran you'll have to prove
that you're clearly the right answer you
got to kind of knock him out to win that
job and you mentioned an important
dynamic draft picks making the team
between draft picks and undrafted free
agents with no offseason program I mean
who knows if there's going to be a week
or two or a mini camp in June but not
the same opportunities to compete that
these young players would have how much
harder is it going to be for the late
round picks the undrafted guys to
actually make it from 90 to 53 yeah I
mean I think rookies this year in
general I think you starting at even
your first second rounders these guys
are gonna have a harder time if assuming
there's no offseason assuming the first
thing let's just say the first time that
we get our hands on is August when
training camp starts well they're
missing all this time and there's only
so much you can do there's so many these
players Mike that you can show them
stuff on the board of the film but they
need to walk through it they need to jog
through it and we're missing a lot of
OTAs and and many camps and things like
that and so you're definitely I remember
back to the lockout here and that's kind
of how we're approaching here is what
can we do with these guys to help them
be as advanced as possible if it's not
til August till they're here and I think
if you go back to 2011 Mike there were a
lot of rookies that didn't get the trust
of the coaches right out of the gate
that were that were drafted high so I do
think get you know even later in the
draft those guys will have a harder time
making your roster and obviously the
under after guys so the undrafted guys
that the main thing will be if they
don't make your roster are they good
enough to be on the practice block and
don't you wish there was a true
Developmental League the AAF tried it
last year the XFL had to pull the plug
due to the pandemic but you've got young
guys who if they just had a chance I
think back to guys like Kurt Warner
going over to NFL Europe the guys who
developed there for a lot of these guys
you get your chance it's a flash and if
you don't make the most of it you're
done because there's another crop of
young players coming in 12 months behind
you yeah no question I mean you know my
I was rooted in Carolina and Jake DeLong
was on that team with Kurt Warner you
know in the arena in the the World
League and I think Jake would say
several times if he didn't get a chance
to go over there and play you know that
he was undrafted out of Louisiana
Lafayette and look at what he did he
took us to a Super Bowl and a really
nice career at least one Pro Bowl I
remember and so the Kurt Warner story
there's plenty of guys that you'll
always wonder what guys are we miss
what guys just needed and the
quarterback play we're talking about two
right here the quarterbacks are hurt the
most and look at a guy we have a guy
named Davis Webb you know who the Giants
took and and then the Jets took the
training camp
Davis is very smart and done a great job
for us though we got him at the 53 cut
down last year put him on the practice
squad and so he's running Scout team all
year he wants to prove now that he knows
the offense that he can he can do it I
would have loved to had a springle to
send him to and let him grow and develop
and watch him but unfortunately and the
next thing is this year we've lost out
OTAs to watch him run our offense so
he's gonna have a condensed window in
August you know to try and show what he
can do maybe one sports come back
there'll be a thirst for a Developmental
League and the NFL will decide just
instead of waiting for someone else to
do it
the NFL will make its own and people
will follow it because we've had a taste
of life without sports and it sucks
so hopefully Sports will be back
hopefully football will be back it's
great to have you back on pft p.m.
Brandi congratulations on the draft
congratulations on restraining yourself
last Thursday night Kentucky and soon
but awesome thanks Mike appreciate your
buddy
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports